[Música]
muchas gracias pues yo hoy vengo a
compartir una historia que me hizo ver
el periodismo con otros ojos con los
ojos de la igualdad
hace algunos años dor en una niña que
creció en un hogar donde era muy mimada
especialmente por su abuelo pero había
algo que no me gusta que no le gustaba
de él y es que él repetía que los
hombres deberían de estudiar y las
mujeres no porque las mujeres iban a
cazar y las iban a mantener
y esto en este ambiente de una cultura
machista donde muchas hemos crecido yo
la niña se preguntaba y que los hombres
no se van a casar y bueno habrá quien
nos pueda mantener también pero esa niña
tenía sueños quería ir a la universidad
y como siempre siempre hay una mujer que
nos inspira o varias mujeres que nos
inspiran en el barrio donde donde creció
esa niña había muchas mujeres con la
edad de universidad y solo dos iban a la
universidad me acuerdo de ellas una le
decía aquí que hay una blanca y ellas
fueron mi inspiración porque yo quería
ir también a la universidad finalmente
ahora tenía sueños y fue a la
universidad y estudió periodismo
y cuando empecé empecé a ejercer el
periodismo me di cuenta que lo que
pasaba en los espacios privados es decir
en el hogar también era trasladado a los
contenidos de los medios de comunicación
ahí las noticias que empezaba a ver yo
eran a las mujeres como víctimas de
delitos en la nota social pero no se
decía cómo estaban aportando las mujeres
a la ciudad de a tamaulipas y fue cuando
empecé a trabajar los temas de mujeres
yo quería saber qué estaban haciendo las
mujeres en tamaulipas en donde estaban
las mujeres cuál eran los problemas a
los que se enfrentaban y empecé a
trabajar el tema de violencia de género
reproducción sexual
y cáncer de mama empecé a trabajar y
hubo una experiencia que me que me
sacudió y que me hizo hacer algo desde
el periodismo por este periodismo de la
igualdad estando yo cubriendo una
noticia de un abuso sexual de una menor
de edad
me tocó ir a cubrir y entré a la señora
la mamá de la niña y pasa el hombre que
abusó de la niña esposado y entran y
cuando él pasa yo estaba atrás y le dice
no me van a hacer nada y la señora está
muy molesta estaba llegan la sientan en
una mesa y la secretaria y enfrente
estaba el hombre esposado
la señora cuando empiezan a empieza la
secretaria apenas de escribir le quita
la pistola al policía que está al lado
de él y mata
al señor que estaba acusado eso me hizo
pensar que estábamos haciendo para
prevenir los los delitos y los abusos y
la violencia que se ejercía contra la
mujer todavía no se hablaba de que era
un problema social
todavía nos incluían en programas en
programas de gobierno del estado
no había muchas activistas que
estuvieran trabajando en estos temas y
fue cuando un grupo de mujeres
periodistas nos dimos a la tarea de
profesionalizar nos en el periodismo de
género de igualitario creamos la red en
el año 2000 creamos la red de mujeres
periodistas empezamos a documentarnos a
todos los derechos de las mujeres que
reforma se estaban dando para
contextualizar estos temas y en esa
década yo me acuerdo que el 24% de las
noticias que se estaban generando en los
contenidos de los medios de comunicación
eran de mujeres es decir se hablaba como
mujer como fuente informativa era la
noticia se decía que estaban haciendo
las mujeres cuántas mujeres estaban
participando en los congresos locales en
las cámaras
y nacional ya se estaba se estaba
generando pero esta cifra se sigue dando
actualmente no hemos cambiado esta cifra
a las mujeres se les sigue viendo se les
sigue hablando como como víctimas de
delitos a las mujeres políticas ahora ya
hay un protocolo de violencia política
contra las mujeres que no es no se está
castigando sólo está como protocolo se
les sigue violentando ya cuando es
candidata y cuando es éste ya
funcionaria se le sigue preguntando a
ellas con quien está casada es el estado
civil la edad en las noticias se les
dice se habla de cómo iban vestidas no
se dice que están haciendo estas mujeres
entonces nosotros empezamos a trabajar
nos organizamos nos profesionalizamos
ahorita somos más de 100 mujeres en todo
tamaulipas que estamos trabajando en
estos temas y en la que queremos
aportar un granito de arena a este a
esta sociedad para hacer un cambio para
incidir en la política pública para que
se haga un cambio de que a las mujeres
se les trate como personas con derecho
no que se etiqueten roles estereotipos
tenemos que romper con estereotipos y
tratar a las mujeres como personas con
derechos yo creo y le ha puesto mucho a
la igualdad como el camino hacia la paz
la violencia que inició en lo privado es
decir en las cuatro paredes de una casa
y que salió a las calles de la ciudad
tenemos que reconstruir la y yo creo que
la sociedad civil es la que está
haciendo las grandes transformaciones en
el mundo en las ciudades aquí tenemos un
ejemplo el libre 17 fue una iniciativa
de la de la sociedad civil no fue una
propuesta de la autoridad nosotros como
red también hicimos una propuesta para
reformar el código penal para que se
protegieran los nombres de las víctimas
de violencia familiar de acoso sexual y
procedió creo que tenemos mucho que
trabajar tenemos que apostarle a estos
cambios de la igualdad y también como
periodistas tenemos mucho trabajo que
hacer
seguimos siguen tratando el tema de las
mujeres como cosa menor no se visibiliza
dicen que se cansan de decirlas y los
hombres y lo que no se visibilice en los
contenidos de los medios de comunicación
no existe tenemos que nombrar a las
mujeres y tenemos que decir qué están
haciendo las mujeres tenemos que generar
más noticias de esto yo creo que todos
tenemos mucho que aportar como sociedad
y tenemos que apoyar a las mujeres ya
los hombres que tenemos que hacer desde
casa creo que tenemos que eliminar los
estéreos
la casa es de todos y de todas y también
tenemos que solidarizarnos con hombres y
mujeres tenemos que apoyar a hombres y
mujeres tenemos que abrir oportunidades
para hombres y mujeres y tratarnos como
personas con derechos yo creo que ese es
el camino hacia la construcción de la
paz y también es el camino hacia la
democracia gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]